[Music]
now senator lindsey graham south
carolina tonight is calling for hearings
on covert questions surrounding this
wuhan virology lab
as we continue to learn that the lab
leak theory was in fact
plausible and credible all along we're
also learning that a 2020 report
utilized by the state department
concluded
that a lab leak was plausible even as
dr doom and gloom dr flip flop fauci
was downplaying and dismissing the
notion despite being warned about the
possibility in his private emails
and breaking tonight get this a new
study from the cleveland clinic is
finding
that unvaccinated people who had covert
have zero difference in re-infection
compared to those who had the virus and
then
also took the vaccine translation
what they are saying tonight it doesn't
look like there's a need to vaccinate
those people that had the virus
it looks like senator rand paul was
right again
here to react to all of this south
carolina senator lindsey graham
well let's just let's first start with
this cleveland clinic
and this new knowledge saying
and and by the way a lot of doctors that
i've been interviewing
on my radio show and elsewhere they've
been saying the same thing
even if your antibody levels go down you
have t-cell
immunity where your body would recognize
if in fact
covet was reintroduced to your body
well why does this matter it matters a
lot because you got a limited amount of
vaccine
so if in fact people have had covered 19
previously don't need the vaccine that
frees up a lot of shots for people
throughout the world right
so science matters here but the big
story this is
this is the russian dossier all over
again this stinks to high heaven this is
lab gate china gate call it whatever you
want to call it
remember when donald trump suggested
this came out of china and there was a
lab leak
remember that senator did the same thing
and by the way everybody
viruses and we all knew that they did
gain a function research
yeah we all knew that and we knew they
had leaks out of the labs in the past
but on february the 19th 2020
when we first had the first cases in
january
27 scientists signed a letter that said
conspiracy theories do nothing but
create fear rumors and prejudice
that jeopardize our global collaborat
collaboration the fight against this
virus
and otherwise in other words 27
scientists
signed a political document shaming
cotton and trump
and anybody else shutting them up the
media took it and ran
and it changed the course of the
election why because number one these
scientists are tied to this lab they
were covering their ass
they put out a letter not based on
science but a political document
trying to destroy the credibility of
people who was suggesting it came out of
the lab
why does this matter if trump was right
about the lab leak it would change the
image the public had of president trump
regarding the coronavirus
more importantly if it came out of the
lab in china he was right that it was
the china virus
and the 2020 election would have been
about who could hold china accountable
trump or biden who would you want in the
room to hold china accountable
for infecting the world is that a
hypothetical
is that a rhetorical question because
the answer is pretty obvious uh
i think putin is going to eat he changed
his lunch and i think president xi would
eat biden's lunch
which is frightening for the u.s and
frankly embarrassing
but here's what we do know ten days
after the first identified case of
corona
january 31st the day that donald trump
put the travel ban in effect that
joe called xenophobic and hysteria
hysterical
that very same day dr fauci received an
email
saying that it looked like the genome
sequence showed manipulation in a lab of
the virus
that's ten days after the first case in
the u.s
then we see a series of emails see
i would call them cya emails talking
about whether the nih
funded this whether or not gain of
function
uh research was was being done with
american money
and outright panic by but fauci went
before
congress and he said things that
directly contradicted what we now know
what was in his own emails
well it's more important than that you
know you did a hell of a job explaining
the russian
ca to the american people how they
ignored every stop sign they wanted an
outcome
not only did fauci ignore the warnings
on february the 19th
a couple of weeks after the first case
27
scientists produced a letter shaming
those who suggested
the lab leak theory calling them
conspiratorial
that you're a right wing nut
marginalizing president trump and tom
cotton
because if trump was right it would have
changed the outcome of the 2020 election
i believe and if we could have proven
and early on in 2020 it was a lab
lab leak coming from china not not
occurring naturally
the public would want revenge against
china and who would they
turn to biden or trump i think this
letter by these scientists
was orchestrated by somebody to shoot
down the idea of the lab leap because
they were worried about their own
being in a slink also their relationship
with china and i think there was a
political motivation here
to destroy trump's credibility if it if
it were known in february that trump was
right of 2020
i think he'd be president today if i did
such a good job
um with the russia investigation could
you please explain where
this guy durham is has there ever been a
durham sighting in the last year
what happened to the report what
happened to the work he was doing
where were the referrals from from
michael horowitz's
the inspector general's report yeah let
me ask you this
yeah you know i'm watching what's going
on
and the way that the liberal media mob
and democrats are reacting to joe
manchin
who actually seems to have read the
constitution and understands that
no voter id no signature verification
no checks and balances or integrity in
elections
is a bad idea and he's being called
everything from a racist on down
same with senator cinema and the same
with getting rid of the legislative
filibuster
as you look at joe biden's agenda
it seems like it's right out of
bolshevik bernie right out of the
radical new greed deal socialist squad
and out of touch with the american
people how does this play out as we head
into 2022 well i think
in 2022 would be a check and balance
election that we're going to win the
house and most likely take back the
senate
because the agenda they're pushing is
not the agenda they ran on
the joe biden this president today is
not the joe biden who ran
in 2020 moderate joe is dead and gone
and the squad runs joe biden
i think we win because of their
overreach but i hope you'll stay on this
china
deal the scientists wrote this letter to
to tamp down and to undercut any idea it
could have come out of this lab to
protect their own butt
and it changed the course of this
election don't let this go sean
last question donald trump this weekend
in north carolina
i think when donald trump says we need
election integrity and competence and
results
and these are the things that we must do
to ensure integrity
when he prosecutes the case against joe
biden and radical socialism
and lays out the american first agenda
the make america great again agenda
those three things i think lead to a
republican wave election
in the next two elections am i wrong
no you're dead right freedom wins out if
it's prosecuted
right and you know they're doing
everything they can to bring the
republican party back we just need to
to make our case all right senator thank
you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else